nous accueillons justin brasier bonsoir
bonsoir la célèbre salle du jeu de paume
de versailles a besoin d'être restaurée
salle qui tient son nom d'un célèbre
événement le serment du jeu de paume
un appel aux dons a été lancé pour
restaurer cette salle oui c'est une
volonté de la part de richard ferrand
donc le président de l'assemblée
nationale
après avoir échangé avec catherine
pégard la présidente du château de
versailles
l'appel a été lancé mardi auprès des
députés il devrait ensuite
progressivement s'ouvrir à l'ensemble
des élus puis à la population alors
pourquoi c'est important de restaurer à
cette salle du jeu de paume et bien
parce qu'elle fait partie de notre
histoire
c'est un symbole de la république et
puis de la démocratie française
écouter didier baichère le député de la
première circonscription des yvelines
on connaît souvent versailles évidemment
pour son château est plutôt pour son
pour des angles de la royauté mais on
sait peu ou pas assez que versailles est
aussi un haut lieu de la constitution de
la république en particulier avec cette
salle du jeu de paume quand même donné
naissance à la déclaration des droits de
l'homme et du citoyen en 1789
donc c c'est important pour l'histoire
de continuer à préserver cet endroit est
de pouvoir l'ouvrir plus largement au
public et le quai le montrer dans un
état que son état d'origine en fait
c'est vous alors j'estime qu'elle sommes
faut-il rassemblés pour permettre cette
restauration alors au total le budget
nécessaire à ces travaux s'élève à 1,8
million d'euros c'est un montant qui a
été évalué par le château de versailles
et les ingénieurs en charge du projet
les travaux devraient concerner à la
toiture les charpentes les jardins mais
aussi la restauration de la toile le
serment du jeu de paume justement de luc
olivier merson d'après le dessin de
jacques louis david
pour l'heure les députés ne peuvent pas
encore faire de don mardi il s'agissait
seulement d'une présentation du projet
par richard ferrand au bureau de
l'assemblée nationale à l'ensemble des
présidents des groupes politiques
mais le dispositif sera mis en place
prochainement et puis une visite sera
organisée pour leur montrer justement
cette salle du jeu de paume